the Joe Rogan experience this is your
unveiling because girl people know that
people know yep that's it first of all
Tatiana
so this is I should have chosen an
easier name like at no one can guess -
Tanya - Tanya because she's named after
the queen of the fairies in Midsummer
Night's Dream tell everybody your real
name
my real name is Andrew Doyle do you have
an issue with people now knowing that
Tatiana or tit - Tanya - Tanya yeah she
totally eclipsed me I don't I'm
basically not alive anymore it's all
about her you know
well I can't remember how I found out
about you on Twitter but just laughing
really hard it's something that you
wrote that was so close you you do such
a good job of like blurring the line
between outrageously woke and satire
yeah it's that thing of trying to who
you are
who's the girl Ronnie throw there okay
yeah so the girl is a composite of four
different women well that's good put
together because I was worried about you
know I don't wanna get sued I'll for
sure yeah so it's not real human but you
know Medical intersectional is that
we're selfless and brave by my work but
also I love that she's dead pan because
it means that she's sort of look every
time I post some it's like there's this
PO faced woman staring at you daring you
yes
don't you dare so challenge me she could
be mean in a way that I'm not well
that's kind of funny you end up
inhabited this character who just isn't
like you and I do I do end up thinking
like her and then and I even I've even
dreamt as her and that sounds like a lie
but I have so that's pretty scary I have
you know she'll have to go eventually
cuz I can't like I can't deal with that
kind of there's a psychosis isn't it
well she's so big now you have 420
thousand followers
it's weird cuz happened really quickly I
guess it's because there's a whole
cohort of people out there who just sick
of this stuff mate yeah you know and I
well it's partly that but also partly
because people still fall for her all
the time people constantly think it's
real you know all the time when I have
retweet you one of my favorite things to
do is read people getting upset you like
that is ridiculous you think that that's
why Trump was winning and right
never ceases to amaze me how angry
people get on Twitter with with you know
even legitimate with legitimate causes
it's like but I watch that and I think
it's fun because I can satirize the left
and the the sort of the most liberal
side of things through her but then I
can argue with the right-wing Trump
supporters and stuff and I can mock them
as well like so you get to have a go at
the extremes yeah I mean and yeah I I'm
so shocked that people still think she's
real though like even after all this
time Oh dad it's not shocking you're
close enough there's plenty of people
and I'll point you did a few of them
that I follow I follow some people where
I just bookmarked them so I don't they
don't know that I follow them yeah and
just some of them are so goddamn [ __ ]
crazy
and yet I keep getting told this is like
a straw man these people don't really
exist yeah they do I even once did a
Jimmy there's a tweet by Rosanna
Arquette who's really really woke risen
her okay yeah I think so she did a tweet
about how ashamed she wasn't being white
and the other that was her I think it
was her and then I just cut and paste
that tweet and put it might have been is
one of the Arquette's yeah but I did the
same tweet I literally cut and paste it
as 2-ton because I thought like this is
and some people got it that I just taken
this other viral tree and some people
got the point I was making but it yeah
it's close to some of them are nuts yes
like like frightening Lee so to to a
point that it's it's a cult flight
behavior it's like it's it's like I
think that the basic principles of you
know standing up against racism sexism
homophobia all that stuff is great yes I
think the the woke movement isn't that
it's a kind of weird cultish pseudo
religious thing that is beyond that so
that you're no longer allowed to make
mistakes you can't be redeemed there's
no there's no it's it's it's it's got
all those hallmarks yes you know it's
like when they are early Christians used
to burn people out of love you know it's
that it's that thing and that's why we
get this kind of counselor culture stuff
and I guess that's why I wanted and
maybe that's why it's popular because
people are sick of treading around on
eggshells worried about being
misinterpreted or even worried about
[ __ ] up and making mistake I mean
what's wrong with saying something
that's every now and then maybe you do
say the wrong thing and
it should be fine if you're a human
being but part of it is also that things
are written down right right and then
when things are written down you can see
them over and over again if you made a
mistake it just said something in normal
human conversation which is how we're
supposed to communicate and how we
normally communicate yeah it just comes
and goes ya know but when it's written
down then it becomes something different
but it's more than that isn't it because
it's it I'll give you an example so
there was a guy who was the editor of a
cookery magazine in the UK and a vegan
freelance journalist emailed him say I'd
love to do a thing about vegans and he
replied and made some joke about yeah
you can do something about will
force-feed the meat and will make them
eat each other and all stupid flippant
thing rather than saying I was really
offended by that can we talk about it I
don't think that's appropriate for you
to email freelance journalist she's
screenshot the thing put it on Twitter
made a thing of it and he had to step
down so I think that's the difference is
whereas like saying to someone look
calling out a mistake or calling someone
out for something they've done that you
perceive to be bad that's that's all
well and good but when you're using it
to advertise how virtuous you are and
and how you you're able to take someone
down for the mistake that they made that
troubles me because then it's no longer
about really about the issue well I
think what we're dealing with when when
you're talking about what culture and I
love that you made this comparison to
radical religion because I think they're
the same patterns I think human beings
have patterns that they follow and you
could say that you're not religious but
you follow these extremely rigid
ideologies that don't allow for any
variation whatsoever you they force 100%
compliance and if you're not 100% in
compliant they will attack you and you
can't be woken up one of the things you
find a religion is people will
especially in the more radical dangerous
and scary religions they'll turn on each
other
oh they turn on each other for not being
pious enough yeah all the time
[Applause]